so here I am on the roof of the house in  Warsaw sunny Warsaw one of our new HMOs  so I'm at that Corner's coming in a  second  well slight query about this window yeah  is that big enough for a forest gate  window or not I haven't actually  measured it but it looks if it's not  what do we have to do we'd have to  either change the hinges to make it open  a bit wider that way we'll change the  window altogether okay what do we have  to knock this out yeah sure cannot get  through that well guess what I just did  the fire escape window I'm not sure  whether this window is big enough or  whether we might need to make it a  little bit bigger and I said hey I can  get through it it's definitely big  enough so how do you know if a fire  escape window is big enough fit Samuel  Eve Stewart and it's a fire escape  window what are your thoughts let us  know  [Music]